do you agree mmm that their ten years
ago there was a sense that microlending
will result in such widespread business
development that poverty would be
alleviated and the new one says that you
just said which is quality of life Lee
improved marginally people can own a
television people can do various things
doesn't reach to the level of what we
would have considered alleviating
poverty at a mass level so what I hear
you say is it is still a benefit and
there are significant benefits but
that's a different question to whether
it's alleviated poverty yeah I think in
some instances it can alleviate poverty
so I believe that more microcredit in
fact where an individual who is able to
grow a business to a certain level that
then has impacts of the following nature
her ability to educate her children say
a female her ability to spend more on
health care and so on there is no
question that that can help to alleviate
poverty I think one of the reasons why
it hasn't perhaps become the silver
bullet is less to do with microfinance
and more to do with the fact that the
continuum of financing in financial
services depending on or oscillating
with the company as it grows that is
available to us in our markets is not
available to these very very small
emerging businesses so if you imagine a
kiosk that then gets there first access
to a micro credit loan who's going to
take them next the reality is that the
traditional financial services are not
willing yet to reach down and give that
person their first $25,000 I think
that's where we've seen a ceiling hit
and so the scalability and potentially
broader poverty deviating impacts then
then hitta seeding as well